whether this number is true or not
exactly the macro headline is absolutely
right
Tick Tock is probably the biggest social
media platform for small businesses
since Facebook and you had to really
know how to use Facebook and Facebook
fan pages the reality is is that if
small businesses uh flower shops baking
shops
uh car shops uh thrift stores small
businesses produced organic content on
Tick Tock the likelihood to go viral
over index instead of getting 15 views
on Instagram or 30 views on a tweet
getting seventy thousand or if they're
active and then an influencer finds
their local donut shop is not too far
away and they come over and make a tick
tock no question and I've been watching
this space for two decades Tick Tock is
the place that small businesses need to
make a huge commitment to to making
organic content post one two times a day
do it smbs